Tom Hiddleston's a new film called
crimson peak it's out on the 16th of
October and I imagine this movie is like
a dream for an actor because it's such a
big gothic melodrama with fights and
frights it's fabbi yeah I mean it is it
was for me it was the chance to work
with Guillermo del Toro who I think is
is a master and it is a Gothic romance
so it's true to gothic romance in that
there is a beautiful radiant pure
hearted heroine played by Mia Basha
coughs Co who is sensational in it and
she's drawn to the Tall Dark Stranger
with the crumbling mansion on the hill
and it's sort of like she's Elizabeth
Bennet and I'm mr. Darcy but when she
gets back to the house it's full of some
crazy and sister and my sister
played by Jessica Chastain who I know
you had on this very so for last week
yes and actually she was walking off the
set and I said to her I saw you in
crimson peak and she was oh I'm so bad
now I know you were going to it no I
play a bad person lucky I didn't go
vignette
zap you mrs. duck times but ever yeah
she's really off the deep end in this
which is which is a new photo she's
fantastic in it too and it's um it
really is about it's about these these
polar opposites of sex and death you
know these these two completely opposite
forces in our lives and I read unusually
as what actor you you negotiated you
lobbied for extra nudity trying to sell
the film love it romance how are you
that were you know Gothic romance ease
it's about sexuality it's about it has
to be sexy and there is a love scene in
the film thank you our cameras like
booth in stumble get naked man you have
to show the world your bonds and it was
I I was happy to do it in it we
discussed it often in these situations
so the woman is more naked than the man
and we thought we would just redress the
balance
what if you do got me boxed in
so welcome so to you on the show